профосвіта терміни і вступні
випробування подавай документи до
профтеху У тебе є час з 1 липня до 31
серпня А якщо не встигнеш зможеш подати
документи під час до набору на вільні
місця до 1 листопада зверни увагу як в
майбутньому студенту про птаху Тобі не
потрібно здавати ЗНО чи національний
мультиппредметний тест детальні умови
вступу дізнавайся на сайті обраного
профтеху у приймальній комісії або на
дні відкритих дверей проходять онлайн як
відбувається конкурсний відбір за
рейтинговим списком вступників за
результатами співбесіди за результатами
середнього балу свідоцтва після 9 або
11-го класу або за результатами вступних
випробувань більше про вступну кампанію
шукай на сайті гон у розділі
професійно-технічна освіта а також на
сторінках Міністерства у соціальних
мережах приклади руку там де її
потребують стовпай до профтеху